what would be advice you would give to
up up and coming managers one that
you've the [__] that you've had to go
through that you know
oh yeah
we gotta believe in them well no they
got to really believe in you
because everybody think it'd just be
like
they don't see all the [__] that the
managers do they don't see all they see
is the glamorous and all that [__] hell
yeah we argue he cussed me out I cuss
him out
but the end of the day is working
like [__] doing [__] that
you know yeah we the [__] they like
yeah you gonna be dead about 10 24 that
[__] like you know what I'm saying like
you just was so horrible well the way
you guys drive no one will ever catch
you yeah I mean yeah but you know we got
we're doing a gun right back two right
which is dope like you know what I'm
saying yeah like I saw that you can pull
up
a little bio gun off the streets that's
another thing too like you know what I'm
saying I haven't seen a lot of [__]
I've seen a lot of [__] get they run
include myself you feel me I've seen a
lot of [__] get they run and coming to
some money but like I'm talking about
[__] that's stronger than man you feel
me like
and that's a skillet and I ain't gonna
say no other names you feel me but as
far as him
I ain't seen a [__] get my [__] back as
soon as you got some money like ever
just like ever like ever like I probably
don't do it two I probably did two
charity things
like within the last
three or four years ago I can remember I
know I was on the fire and we did
something like maybe three this [__]
did like yeah he just had it
a year and a half or two weeks ago
literally like he probably did like 10
children events in the last charity
basketball game we went to Footlocker
and brought the kids 200 pair of shoes
and he's different why is that so
important for you to make sure you're
doing
I just remember uh growing up and I like
like I was in high school inside I got
like big and stuff
and like here we had big rappers in the
city like to us yeah and I just wish
they would have reached back to us like
I wish I could touch like that get that
get that would have gave me hope like
right I missed out of that 19. you gave
me hope like I was working struggling
got put out the house all type of [__]
doing all type of [__] I shouldn't do
and being touched by somebody I I it
don't even got to be money or nothing
it's just knowing that like I'm around
some [__] that could change my life
while I'm around somebody or you just
didn't change their life it's like you
you see someone on TV or on Instagram
but if you actually like
to use the word touch it's like you see
them and you they're really there like
oh [__] actually technology and let the
kids touch me just so they can know like
this a real person it's not somebody I
see on TV and right he's not from here
like I'm really familiar I care about
your I remember sitting in the seat the
same schools that y'all was at so it's
important for us to go back and reach
back and let them know that like I was
sitting in your same seat you can sit in
my same seat when you get old as me like
you know yeah he he's so [__]
selfless just like
it's like if if you guys are leaders you
guys gotta lead by example you know that
motivated I ain't gonna say names but it
motivated a lot of people to squash what
they had going on for them you know
better of the city and how it looked
they see how they look they see how tea
inside of look they see how viral they
went they see how because it I think the
world lack a lot of positivity and it'd
be a lot of soft ass [__] that
wouldn't hurt nobody want to see people
be violent in drama 100 sure
it's like the the life we are not like
as many [__] that would was
of course the positive I weighed the
negative with that situation with me and
bro but as many [__] was happy
you know it's still [__] that
wish we would have still stay mad at
each other yeah just because of that
narrative you feel me you know what I'm
saying like that that that's that's the
narrative that's more enticing for some
people but it's so stupid yeah you know
what I'm saying like [__] that the
other [__] don't get way more hero did
like it's supposed to and it took more I
feel like it took more for y'all to let
[__] go to to escalate it like it take
like I could go do something to somebody
so quick but it'd be like it take
everything it takes some real [__]
forgive yeah everything yeah be real
yeah actually to be a man first and be
like you know what
even if you like that [__] way harder
and people like my circle to check me if
I'm wrong yeah I don't give a [__] it's
all right cause he gonna tell me if I'm
wrong
it's just way harder relationship go for
sure everybody know that and I just come
in Saturn and T for doing that though
and everybody think it's because of me
no it's because of them like they really
wanted to do that they was talking for a
minute and the first 10 seconds of them
talking I seen them smiling so it wasn't
really that big of a deal
great
uh all right so new music on the way
from everybody obviously it's going
crazy low CD Babs if I'm if I'm gonna
just put that in there we just we going
forward we're releasing the songs that
we think that people will want to hear
and have okay that's it there it is man
I appreciate y'all pulling up take care
of my big Squad read the most
yeah it's September 30 y'all pull up
Detroit
Nation like real like a real real real
event International Players [__]
Masonic Temple Masonic temples September
3rd is that where they do like yeah
masonry like it's like a Freemason
they do there's Freemasons
we gonna be there September 30th if
somebody gonna be there t gonna be there
G herbo the kids
September
girls you never know who goes outside
from 808 you might see them in that
[__]
we ain't gonna see you [__] we is not
gonna see you [__] bro [__]
that was great
pickleball's lit right now
man make sure y'all pop up man we love
Detroit shout out to everybody doing
their thing you know my next interview I
don't care because you know like I'm a
frequent Claire flyer so yeah flyer so
yeah like my next interview I gotta do
one of the um the intermission
commercials yeah yeah just like that
yeah like that this this this episode of
bootleg Kev is sponsored by Don Julio
Anejo liquor nope it's not we eat the
most nope it's not weed the most
subscribe we eat the most Odd Socks
foreign
good looking there you go yeah man are
you out or are the socks odd Kim I
appreciate you too man you always
showing this love of course man I'm
saying gotta get you back out there I'll
be in Detroit soon I actually really
thoroughly enjoyed my time there is
September 30th oh yeah
Corner Store brunch no no no we need to
do it no no no we do we do we do we're
gonna make it work yeah we'll do a
Cornerstone wrench too yeah yeah
socks right now there it is
all right
boom